Shoal pants who wants to make more money
me too thank you what do you think your
financial advisor would say if you asked
him this question and how Nobel
prize-winning economist
Harry Markowitz once said that he would
never be a hundred percent invested in
stocks or bonds or cash hmm if you think
about it games are now so different
would you bet your entire revenue stream
on one source of income a more
sustainable revenue model calls for a
mindset shift our industry seems to
operate in the way that your
monetization model is determined by your
John rrah
ads for hyper casual IP for estimable
and subscriptions for PC and console
this has worked so far but in this talk
I'd like to invite all of you to
challenge these assumptions together
with me our economy's friend Harry said
that we shouldn't put all our eggs in
the same basket
can we take learning from other genre
and treating a current strategy no rule
saying that you have to do something
just because you're born this way right
in 15 minutes you hear from one of your
peers about their innovation but first
let me set the stage and talk about
monetization diversification the why the
what and the how why diversify our
economist friend Harry said that we
should balance our income sources
because it decreases risk and increases
revenue true or not true if you disagree
come find me after this talk well you
might not know is that we also have big
data to back up this claim we plotted
the top-grossing games on this graph to
your right
each dot is a game on the x-axis it's a
percentage of the games revenue driven
by its top 5% of buyers on the y-axis is
the game's churn buyers reactivation
rate this means that the more to the
right the more concentrated use your
games revenue this negative correlation
shows that if a game squeezes its buyers
then they're also less likely to come
back if they ever leave therefore we
call this philosophy one dollar out of
every one is more sustainable than $100
out of one player now if a couch was
thinking about their versification let's
touch on some of the trends we've
observed subscriptions rewarded adds an
IEP raise your hand if you have at least
one of these implemented what about two
of these all three good for you
so here's the deal I would not claim
that everything I'll be sharing with you
today will be groundbreaking but my hope
for you is that after this talk you have
learned something new and more
importantly find the inspiration for
your pure stories to try something new
and add to your current strategy now
raise your hand if you have
subscriptions in your games are you
thinking about it
really if you're thinking about it
awesome subscriptions is not a foreign
concept in gaming from PC to console
many have used subscriptions as a
content path however today I'd like to
talk to you about a different kind of
subscriptions instead of bundles how are
mobile games layering subscriptions on
top of IEP to create different tiers of
premium experiences the momentum around
subscription has accelerated on mobile
in recent years on play we've seen a
global mobile gaming subscription
squirrel's a 70 percent year-over-year
in fact those who implement
subscriptions reported a boost in both
retention and revenue mix he saw 20%
more play and scully reported high LTV
when they have subscriptions if those
are not enough reasons for you a Google
i/o earlier this year and also this
morning we talked about digital
while being many top developers like
Obon are prioritizing sustainable grills
so I challenge you
leaders in mobile gaming industry to
think about what is digital whopping
look like as a mobile game with
subscriptions can we restructure short
term impulse buys into a long term
sustainable benefits maybe instead of
eating all of your Halloween candies in
one go
and possibly regretted next morning
can't wait instead have something sweet
every day for the next few months
designing subscriptions requires a
mindset shift from IP it maybe it's
happening to repacked
IP skews into subscription bundles it
works but there's so much more you can
do the key word here is access the main
difference between IP and subscription
is that while eiope is about ownership
where the users get to keep what they
buy subscriptions about access access of
different tiers of prima experiences and
access that you can gain and lose there
are two main use cases of subscriptions
the first is aimed at converting new
buyers these buyers are often motivated
by a good financial deal Scopus
subscriptions offer exclusive rewards
that a early bart would want on top of
the IEP deal service right after photo e
with loss protection and higher daily
caps this situation aims to increase
these early buyers time spending game to
form a habit of playing still early in
their life cycle the second use case of
in-game subscriptions is to create a
loyalty program for your high-value
buyers much like the mileage program by
Airlines these players are often
motivated by prestige rewards for the
commitment in your game or just a little
bit more premium experience ludia offers
their VIP subscribers extra currency
exclusive tournaments early access and
new content
and access again the keywords access to
a special durable that may even
strengthen with time designing access is
key to make you in-game subscription
additive to your existing I AP economy
if you're thinking okay what about
cannibalization hold that thought and a
wait for Fey now raise your hand if you
have what it adds implementing your
games awesome those wish your hands
raised you can take a nap now although
you might want to stay awake for
something that may be a surprise to you
earlier this year the Google AdMob team
conducted their research and uncovered a
growing segment of developers who are
previously IEP only are now rethinking
their overall monetization strategy and
as a result are implementing rewarded
apps there are three main reasons why
you should think about rewarded ads the
first election while enticing non-payers
especially in developing countries
emerging markets these players while
they might be more reluctant to take out
the wallet and make purchases they might
be more willing to trade with their time
instead the second benefit is I also
increases overall engagement across
buyers and non buyers many game
developers use through what it adds as a
way to extend gameplay or gift a minimal
amount of IP this increased time spent
for everyone which in turn increases
social liquidity which that enhance the
experience of everybody playing now the
third reason which may be a surprise to
you is that you also predict IP
conversion congregate found that across
six other games players who watched an
ad in their very first session are 2.5
to five times more likely to make
subsequent purchases of course we can't
say that watching an ad will cause you
to spend but there is a clear
correlation between the group of people
who watch ads
and the group of people who are likely
to make in that purchases now AdMob also
share with us a framework to help you
optimize your what it asked design let's
see what Kongregate has to say for each
of these for placement what it adds
should be core to your gameplay as part
of your in-game economy the reward
itself should be useful meaningful while
not competing directly with IEP for
targeting everybody should have access
to what it adds but the user should
initiate the experience as to ensure to
not interrupt their gameplay
for kayden's more isn't necessarily
better congregate found that six to
eight ad views per viewer per day
maximizes return with the option to
watch at least one procession for
measurement
remember to segment your core health
metrics by app viewership and frequency
and if you notice a certain cohort users
are spending less time or money test and
iterate use this framework now if you're
itching to test out real what it adds
quickly this morning we announce
rewarded products that's coming soon
directly in your console this uses the
same API calls as IP if you're
interested talk to you' 'play bt manager
lastly IG I will not ask for hints as I
assume most of you have IP implemented
but for now place that and here why game
developer who found success previously
with ads are now also pushing for IEP
similar to the trend with rewarded as
well IP itself is in you what is new is
the growing number of developers who are
previously ads only are now adding IP to
the existing titles or developing new IP
based titles to increase their portfolio
diversity for example taps games a
Brazilian developer is known for their
high / - okay
but decided to focus on IP in the bid
wars titles after growing the IP revenue
by 200% and more IP is now an integral
part of the strategy let's remind
ourselves the advantages of IP first it
can be run and developed by simple team
but nimble team is simple infrastructure
we've seen teams as small as 10 people
managing multi-million dollar titles
second instead of rely on a huge user
base or massive installs IP pushes us to
think about long term sustainable
business metrics and last IP gives you
control and flexibility over your game
and your revenue now for those of you
thinking about
ap let's quickly touch on the design
framework you don't want is the pub
Chinese publisher of rodeo Stampede do
manage to shift their ass to IP ratio
from 30% IP to 60% IEP let's see what I
recommend for design keep it simple and
flexible while to the month has as many
users as possible but given the user
their choice of currency such as IP or
ads for conversion I understand what
uniquely motivates each segment of your
users will help you create targeted
offers and for retention content is king
and build a customizable LiveOps system
early which will save you time later on
now without further ado I'd like to
introduce Fei who leads operations from
Network so talk to you more about
in-game subscriptions
[Applause]
okay thank you moonlit hi everyone i'm
faye griffin i'm vp of operations at
network who are we we are 90 people
headquartered in San Francisco with
offices in LA and Santiago Chile we
believe there are five features that
make up a great game gotcha
we still got your card packs every week
and for those of you you don't know
aren't familiar with gotcha card packs
ink pokemon or baseball cards we
introduce rarity in our game we have
weekly events we run we have social
component in our game guilds we also
have a store our first game out in the
market that combines all of these
features is legendary game of heroes an
overview of legendary it's two years old
we have guilds in the game we run weekly
events it's primarily I ap driven and we
have VIP subscriptions so today I'm
gonna talk to you about subscriptions
and why you should care but before I do
that I'm just gonna give you 30 seconds
on our business model most of our
players don't pay but we have a very
small percentage of players who do pay
now we care about all of our players
coming back every day month over month
year after year but we especially care
about that small percent who do pay so
when we thought about subscriptions we
saw an opportunity to be generous we'd
happily give away $100 in value every
month if we knew you were going to show
up every day month after month year
after year and it's working since we
introduced subscriptions last April our
subscription base has grown month over
month so we're doing something right few
top lines about our subscriptions in
legendary we brand our subscriptions as
VIP and during this talk I'm going to
use those terms interchangeably
subscriptions in VIP
it's $29.99 a month our VIP are small
but growing portion of our revenue we
have 30,000 active
subscribers we have a day 425 retention
of 20% with our VIP actives we have a 90
percent 95 percent login rate of VIPs
and so far cannibalization is not a
factor and our cost per player is
coverable by our VIPs some key
considerations we thought about when
introducing VIP subscriptions we thought
of subscriptions as a loyalty program
that provide premium access another
thing to think about is monthly versus
yearly access right now we just have
monthly and I'm going to tell you a
little story about why so one of the
unique things about our culture at
Network is that we believe great ideas
can come from anywhere and our
subscriptions actually came from our one
of our client engineers on legendary
shoe he came to us and said hey Google's
now offering the ability to do
subscriptions I think we should put that
in our game should be like the Amazon
Prime of subscriptions for legendary so
we got a great feature from our client
engineer but the downside was we didn't
have a 20-person design team thinking
about it so we didn't think of all the
ins and outs of subscriptions when we
first implemented it so we got a really
great system but some constraints and
that it's not as extensible as we would
like it to be but we're fixing that now
another thing to think about is how much
you can discount IA p for the promise of
future revenue the bet we made was that
subscriptions would be highly retentive
so we bet long term future revenue would
benefit us the other thing to think
about is that subscriptions must provide
convenience to the player you should
make it a no brainer a subscription
player after having experience playing
the game with subscriptions cannot
imagine playing the game ever again
without a subscription the other thing
you need to consider is rewarding and
celebrating your loyal subscribers
celebrate celebrate celebrate through
VIP events
VIP offers our VIPs can actually reach
us any time of the day to give us
feedback subscriber players must feel
like they belong to a community that's
appreciated by the game devs anti
subscriptions to loyalty programs
whenever possible so some challenges I'm
going to talk about intuitive messaging
and standout UX together because they
kind of go hand in hand
one thing we asked ourselves was how do
we communicate VIP benefits in as clear
way as possible with as few words as
possible one of the ways you can do that
is by differentiating what the game
looks like for non subscribers versus
subscribers one way we did this was
through color our non subscribers the
steady state of the game is blue for our
subscribers it's purple color of royalty
everywhere you get a VIP benefit we
themed at purple as you can see from the
mock-up on the screen if you turn off
VIP the game looks very different for
you it's pretty obvious we built it into
the core loop if you play as a VIP you
can't help but see the benefits if you
turn it off it's obvious everywhere you
lost something is super clear we also
think of our VIPs they're not only VIPs
in the game but also outside of the game
we actually have a slack channel where
our VIPs can communicate with us their
customer service tickets get flagged and
they're handled separately every
interaction a subscriber player has must
be a moment of delight and reinforced
that they are a VIP another thing to
think about is when to sell
subscriptions we run weekly events so we
might put a pop-up in the game a day
before an event starts to advertise how
what you get out of a VIP subscription
can help you in the events this one I
put in here from for the devs shared
account prevention we needed a way we
needed to build into a system a way to
prevent multiple players who share a
single Google account from exploiting
and get unfair advantages and lastly you
need to ensure that you have
high-caliber customer support and that
your customer support team is properly
equipped to benefit your subscribers so
I a versus subscriptions many people
think of subscriptions are just Auto
renewal of IIP but we think of them very
differently to echo what moonlets said
earlier subscriptions are access their
highly retentive long-term access to
content I ap is content it's a one-time
situational purchase of content
conceptually we think of them very
differently
subscriptions help underwrite our
revenue and improve our payer retention
it also gives us a way to personalize
IEP offers based on a player's
subscription tier rather than having one
storefront for everyone subscriptions
can boost I ap economy through increased
value of products for subscribers and
this is at no cost to other ia P
products in other words we have seen no
cannibalization some things we wish we
considered Google subscription service
has some really great features free
trials Auto renewal of trials and deals
so for instance three months at a
discounted price timecards providing an
alternative I a p2 gained temporary
access to subscribing so for example
like a three month Xbox Live card those
are all things that are currently on our
roadmap now if I'm to leave you with
three key learnings one would be given
its high retention VIP subscription
should be the number one thing people
buy it should be a no-brainer to them
the value they get out of it is a
no-brainer too framing is everything
celebrate celebrate celebrate your VIP
subscribers both inside and outside the
game and lastly build fast that maintain
the ability to iterate this is where we
are now thanks so much for your time and
with that I'll give it back to midlet
Thank You Faye now let's conclude a
session as you think about takeaways for
this session I have three hopes for you
first I hope you found the inspiration
to go back and reinvent your
monetization strategy second I hope that
you believe now your past does
necessarily dictate your future and
third I hope you would go back to your
teams and ask them why shouldn't we
diversify more with this I'll end the
session with one question for you when
was the last time you had a sit-down
meeting with your team to actively
decide the current status quo is also
the best strategy going forward thank
you